[Music]
good evening I'm Alexander Rose the
executive director at the long now
foundation as many of you know we have
long been working on the renovation of
our space at Fort Mason and we've been
calling it the salon kind of generically
but we finally decided on a name it is
called the interval basically the space
in-between and we are the construction
is just now finishing up the bookshelves
are all in and many of you I assume have
been seeing some of the book lists we've
been publishing for the 3,000 volume
manual for civilization book lists have
been coming in from people like Maria
Popova Kevin Kelly Stewart Brand
Neil Gaiman just agreed to do a list of
books on storytelling which ought to be
fantastic so those are all coming in and
we will probably have at least a
thousand of those volumes on our shelves
will also be soon sending out the the
list of the first thousand books that we
would really love to get used and
donated so we don't have to buy them new
and cut down more trees so hopefully
some of you have a lot of these books in
your collection the other little bits of
news are that the chalkboard robot some
of you may remember that part of the
design you can see it up there that
chalkboard is actually a robot it's now
being built by your Glenny and
Switzerland who's already built several
chalkboard robots we found him kind of
at the last minute thought we had
invented the idea but he had and and
there's still more opportunities to
sponsor a bottle or a shelf and it will
be filled with the gin or whiskey of
your choice before we open and so please
please do were the last about $75,000
with the fundraising that we need to do
and then we'll actually be able to pay
our contractors as they finish up and
open our doors so that will be great
so now I'm going to introduce our long
short for this evening many of you know
we often do a short film about long-term
thinking and this one I think is
particularly apropos for tonight
basically a 50-year Deep Space Network
project that clearly would never have
been done with private money Deep Space
Network is basically required to do the
kinds of things that we do in space
clearly if you can't talk to your
spacecraft and they can't talk to you
there's no point and they even send them
out there the Deep Space Network makes
everything that we do possible imagine
landing light for example for curiosity
without the Deep Space Network there'd
be no one in there because there be
nothing to see they need to hear nothing
from the spacecraft
no touchdown confirm no cheering no
nothing the Deep Space Network is what
helps us figure out where the spacecraft
is we wouldn't even get close to Mars
without it the Deep Space Network
comprises of three complexes around the
world based about 120 degrees apart this
ensures us that we are constantly in
touch with the spacecraft as the Earth
rotates were today tracking 33
spacecrafts not only the u.s. spacecraft
were shorter spacecrafts from other
countries and remember this is not only
talking to the spacecraft we have been
able to do radar and radio astronomy and
it was the radar on this antenna that
actually was used for even the men
landing on
fifty years ago director of JPL dr.
Pickering and NASA established the Deep
Space Network to provide communications
for all the deep-space missions
rather than having each of the missions
build their own ground network we used
to use big analog recorders for
telemetry signals we used a 2-inch wide
tape in the beginning the first
computers we put in we had 64,000 words
maximum and we had to be able to support
every mission NASA missions other
foreign missions and digital technology
and computers allowed that to happen if
you look at the Cassini mission we've
got a transmitter about an average of
eight hundred nine hundred million miles
away the transmitters about the power of
your refrigerator light bulb and that is
what is bringing all these incredible
images and data back I think it's a
resource to be treasured but it's a
resource that also needs to be nourished
we are looking at missions with higher
data rate more complicated missions with
more instruments on the missions we are
looking at optical comm with optical
comm one day we should have streaming
videos you can see real-time rather than
a simulation seeing our success in in
almost real-time and annoying right away
and seeing those pictures all possible
because the DSA if there was no DHN
there would be no missions we always
remind the missions don't leave the
earth without us
[Music]
don't leave the earth without me
good evening I'm Stuart brand from long
now foundation a long-term thinking be
encouraged it and that all sounds kind
of like well that's probably
conservative thinking actually long-term
thinking can and should be radical which
then gets you into the field of
innovation which then gets you into
layers and levels of innovation
gesturing toward depth here and
innovations usually recur within the
field so then who starts the field who
is thinking so far ahead so far toward
the horizon who is dealing with an
entity so big and slow and hard to steer
that they have to think at horizon level
that's one of the things we hire
government to do and one of the few
people who's really examined how that
whole process works is our speaker
Mariana Matsu cata
[Applause]
thank you very much Stuart and thanks to
you all for coming here my objective is
to convince you in the next 45 minutes
which is how long I'm going to talk that
we absolutely have to change the words
the way we talk about the state if we
want to nurture whatever you want today
is talking about which is the need for
public-private partnerships because I
think that while we know and while we
talk a lot about the private sector and
how important it is to drive innovation
to drive growth to produce the kind of
Silicon Valley type dynamics we have not
only under estimated under talked about
the role of the state but actually the
words we use to talk about it both in
economic theory which I'll talk a little
bit about but also just in common date
jargon and the media and also the words
that politicians use is extremely
problematic and is actually bad not just
for the future of innovation but also
for our ability to attack the big
challenges today which are you know what
kind of growth do we actually want we
are in a moment where we've just
experienced probably the worst or one of
the worst stuff cuz we sometimes forget
about the previous ones but worse
financial crises where countries all
over the world the US Europe Latin
America and Africa are trying to nurture
a post crisis recovery and in some cases
especially in the anglo-saxon countries
so the UK in the u.s. to rebalance away
from speculative finance towards the
real economy and so you know Industrial
Policy is actually back it's no longer a
bad word but really you know
policymakers are also saying that we
don't just want smart innovation led
growth which is extremely important but
we also want that growth to be more
inclusive less inequality and more
sustainable
so sustainable over time we cannot keep
using resources at the level that we
have without thinking about the long
term sustainability of that growth and
the real problem here is that you know
this actually requires massive
big creative thinking and the public
sector obviously has a huge role in the
policies around that space and we have a
massive crisis I think today one of the
biggest crises is not just the financial
crisis but the crisis in thinking and
this is really my objective to you know
nurture at least here especially later
in the question time conversation about
how we can actually change the way we
talk about the public sectors the
state's role in this massive
transformational process that we need
and just some background how economists
talk about this problem and this is
important how how economists talk about
it Kane so you probably know John
Maynard Keynes who was an economist who
is known to be probably the most
important for actually talking about the
role of government he also had this
wonderful quote where he said you know
practical men and women who think they
are completely devoid of any sort of
political influence and influence of you
know sort of economic theory are
actually the slaves of defunct
economists so economic theory is
actually out there determining how
policymakers and journalists and also
just the common man and woman in the
street often talk about things without
them even knowing what that theory is
and so what I want to talk to you first
here and my first slide is that how
economists talk about the role of the
public sector is very very limited it's
about fixing different types of problems
in the market the most typical problem
is that when you have a public good like
basic research which is very hard to
appropriate the returns from that then
you have a market failure and so the
government actually has to intervene and
fund that also when you have different
types of positive and Network
externalities when you have again I'll
use the the example of basic research
you have very strong positive
externalities in other words the spill
overs are very high that's one of the
reasons why it's also very hard to
appropriate the return so in different
areas where you have high spill overs
education defense spending clean air you
have not enough private invest
and so the government has to come in
okay now there's very little debate
about this okay so the reason I speak
like you know I sound American but I'm
actually Italian and Stuart did a great
job in pronouncing my name even though
when he asked me how should I pronounce
it I said pretend I'm Japanese because
then it sounds you know Matt's capital
which actually means Christmas tree
apparently or something like Christmas
tree in Japanese and the reason I sound
American is because when I was five
years old we came to America because my
father is the nuclear fusion physicist
and that's an area where it's you know
pretty commonly understood that of
course that's gonna be government-funded
because it's you know once it's actually
going to be discovered it's gonna be
extremely hard for any private sector
organization to appropriate the profits
from it right because it's a big
discovery which will be known to all now
this is extremely limited view okay so
market failures of course they exist you
know we now know today that they exist
more than ever after this massive types
of financial market failures that we
just had but it's it's it's interesting
that in order to actually tackle those
problems you know smart innovation led
growth which is also inclusive which is
also sustainable if you had government
that was just fixing different types of
market failures you can imagine it's
gonna be quite hard to tackle those
challenges and I have found in my own
work very inspiring this work by Karl
Polanyi
he was a sociologist and sort of
historian in between those two fields
who really shed light on you know what
the role of the state has been in the
history of capitalism he actually takes
the word the market and really
decomposes it what he says is that local
markets you know selling kind of fruit
and vegetables on the corner of a street
and international markets are actually
you know really predate capitalism
they've been around for kind of 3,000
years but the capitalist market which is
usually what we talk about when we use
the word market is very recent it's only
about 250 years old and it's not natural
in any way it was actually imposed by
the state not just by laws but different
types of funding and that book itself I
think is one of the most important books
to really deep
if you want the way we usually talk
about the state versus market I'm not
going to go into that kind of historical
perspective I'm going to be focusing at
least in the first part of my talk on
innovation and what we know the role of
the state has been but it's a very
important book which I recommend you
read because it just shows that even
when we're just talking about the market
in general we have to understand that
it's actually the outcome of different
types of organizations and this by the
way is very important because today you
know coming back to this problem of
short-term and long-term thinking we
often hear you know that it's somehow
the market which is making particular
companies short-term ist's and thinking
too much about their quarterly profits
but actually you then look at particular
types of orders which I'll be mentioning
later and you see massively different
ways in which companies in those sectors
are reacting to market pressures and you
know markets are outcomes outcomes of
what of organizations with types of
organizations government organizations
business organizations and household
organizations so again one of the
objectives I have is also to convince
you to start thinking about that what
kind of business organizations and what
kind of government organizations I won't
be talking so much about households do
we actually need today to achieve the
kind of growth that we want instead of
thinking public versus private business
versus States so now what's interesting
is that the way you know this
conversation about government is just
fixing these market failures leads to
what I said was a very narrow view which
is this view that somehow yes of course
governments importance but it's only
important in this very restricted domain
you know this is an example from the
Economist which is saying that
government should stick to the basics
and what those basics are or in fact
these kind of public good areas right so
infrastructure education research okay
this was a special issue that was
thinking about you know what's the next
big thing after the internet they were
talking about nanotechnology green
technology they were very explicit as
The Economist often is in the editorial
section
and they said you know government okay
you you know of course we need
government you know also just for
private property and you know proper
legal system but stay in your place
because what's gonna you know lead the
revolution or the revolutionaries and
who are the revolutionaries well you are
sitting in San Francisco very close to
all these revolutionary guys it's the
Steve Jobs is jobs is the Zuckerberg you
know the Facebook's the Amazons the
Twitter's those kinds of organizations
and people that led to them and while we
need government and we also know that
you know bureaucracy sort of needed of
course whoops that went too quickly what
we need government to do is to stay you
know restricted why because what we want
is change we want dynamism we want the
kind of you know hunger and foolishness
that Jeep's job Steve Jobs talked about
but government you know it's not going
to achieve that and if it in fact gets
to be too big it's gonna in fact impede
that kind of dynamism that we want in
order to achieve the smarts innovation
led growth and so in fact policymakers
and I talk to policymakers all the time
I live in Europe and London so I talk to
mainly European policymakers but I find
that this image is actually pretty
international this image being that you
have business which is sort of in a cage
okay there's different types of
impediments not allowing it to really
kind of roar right so you have a lion in
a cage and the role of government
besides funding the basics is also to
slowly take away these impediments and
so different types of taxes right tax
incentives reduction of tax but also
tinkering with whether it's R&D tax or
other types of tax incentives but
especially taking away all this red tape
this bureaucracy this regulation okay
this view of business as a roaring lion
in a cage and government important for
creating the conditions for that lion to
rage roar and create that innovation
knowledge economy and also government to
take away these impediments is extremely
strong
in fact if you look at lots of the
post-crisis policies that are trying to
foster this kind of innovation at least
in the UK for example I count as
something like 14 new types of tax
incentives right so that's about taking
away the impediments and the assumption
that then this lines going to come out
that what's very interesting about this
quote which is again Keynes this quote
John Maynard Keynes who's one of the
most important economists who actually
thought about the role of government in
the economy right or wrong it's not the
point but he's probably the biggest
thinker about why government is actually
required to intervene in the capitalist
economy he actually got a bit stuck you
know this is a wonderful letter it was
actually a private letter no longer as
you're all looking at it that he wrote
to Roosevelt in 1938 where I'm not gonna
be the whole quote but he's kind of
saying mmm well I used this word animal
spirits right so the word animal spirits
came from his analysis of why you
actually need a government to intervene
he said if you look at GDP which is how
we calculate growth you have consumption
expenditure private business investment
government expenditure net exports C
plus I plus G Plus X minus n I private
business investment is the one he
focused on a lot he said its to
procyclical
and it's also always very volatile okay
in fact if you're ever interested in in
looking at this data just get an excel
sheet hopefully you know how to use it
unlike a Reiner and Rogoff who we know
had problems with it but no comment that
wasn't very nice and you actually plot
investment you can get this data from
the government Bureau of Economic
Analysis website and you come and you
just plot it over time it really is like
that whereas consumption expenditure
which is one of the biggest components
of GDP is actually quite stable okay
it's more or less a monotonic function
of disposable income and what he said is
that the reason you know well first of
all that the fact that this I is so
volatile is the reason you need G to
come in government expenditure to
stabilize aggregate demand but what was
interesting was the word he used
to describe I write he said it's driven
by animal spirits okay so that's why
it's so volatile so you can't just
tinker with tax and interest rates and
get it to increase because what animal
spirits is or are is the gut instinct
about where the future technological and
market opportunities are okay and he
said because that's quite uncertain and
really uncertain it's not just risky
it's uncertain so completely
unpredictable it's very hard to manage
that I just with tinkering with tax and
interests that's why government has to
stand ready to inject a demand in you
know times of recessions especially and
in this letter he's kind of like
thinking to himself because this has not
been taken up by any of the big
Keynesian economists you know people
like Stiglitz and and Krugman who write
in the media today I don't think I've
thought enough about this question here
which is oh dear what if it's not wolves
tigers and lions in that cage but what
if it's like a gerbil or a pussycat you
know that's gonna be very different in
terms of policymakers now I'm kind of
embellishing what probably was going on
is in his head because this was also
obviously a very specific time in which
he's writing but let me just say what
I'm thinking you know what if it is a
domesticated animal then not a line and
wolf and tiger mmm the role of policy is
no longer just to take away the
impediments and let this lion roar it's
actually to get that pussycat to grow
into a lion to actually get the courage
up to want to invest okay and today by
the way where we have record level
hoarding rates right there there there's
no lack of money there's just a complete
lack of courage to be investing in the
US the the hoarding rate of the private
sector today is close to two trillion
dollars in the u.s. it's sorry in Europe
it's close to 1 trillion but this isn't
just since the crisis you you we we have
lots of hoarding going on
lack of want to invest this is a huge
problem for policy makers how to unlock
it and if you're just thinking that you
have to take away the impediments
it's gonna be much harder if in that
cage you have again a gerbil now Warren
Buffett who is an extremely smart man we
know because also he's made all sorts of
money using this smart even though I
think I've often for others it's been
just being at the right place at the
right time that this guy has
consistently made lots of money from
some of his knowledge I think this is an
extremely important quote which actually
supports what Keynes is trying to say
which is that you know investment is not
about just taking you know making it
easier he says you know when capital
gains rates were quite high and I'm
gonna come back to that rate by the way
so remember the year he actually put up
their 1976 capital gains in the US was
close to 40% in a 1981 it was already 50
percent less than that and since then
has been coming down I'll come back to
this point later but he says people
invest to make money and potential taxes
so costs of that investment have never
scared them off so you invest when you
have those gut instincts about where
these future opportunities are okay this
is a radical point and this comes back
to the whole animal spirit so then the
question really is you know what then
drives those new opportunities those
technological and market opportunities
which are so important for driving
business investment which isn't a very
important part of GDP and where is the
revolutionary coming back to that
economists quote if you want spirit of
those investments is it true that
government is just completely inertial
bureaucratic and only needed to create
the conditions for this revolutionary
private sector to do their thing and and
I think it's very illustrative to then
think about you know particular types of
technologies not just going from an
iphone4 to an iphone5 but you know
revolutionary general purpose
technologies which have affected how all
sectors work ok that's what a general
purpose technology means a new
technology which really radically
increases for example productivity in
sectors beyond the particular area where
it emerged
and what's absolutely fascinating about
all these examples nonotuck the internet
biotech and I'll give you some data
later on the emerging green if you want
space internationally is that what
government did and I'll focus mainly on
the US and in these examples but
increasingly it's outside of the US did
so much more than just fix the public
good problem okay so this is the
innovation chain from basic research to
product commercialization and the orange
names there are public sector
organizations in the u.s. state
organizations which played an absolutely
pivotal role a revolutionary role and a
mission oriented role this is a very
important point so many of the
investments that led to those general
purpose technologies were not fixing
market failures they were actually
creating big missions government was
thinking big it was thinking in a
revolutionary pretty radical way from
putting a man on the moon which actually
required 17 different sectors to
interact to thinking of the internet
before the internet existed thinking of
nanotech the word nanotechnology itself
came out of scientists who were working
within the National Science Foundation
that story is very well described in a
particular book and what's also
interesting here is that the the
early-stage funds for many of the
companies were provided by the public
sector so let me just move on to that
particular graph yeah so you know when
you think of early stage seed finance
this extremely risky in the in the early
stage that's why it's called early stage
seed finance and what's striking is that
it was often government funding in
particular through this Small Business
Innovation research program but also the
SBIC STTR all public funds which have
been even more important in private
venture capital so Apple compact Intel
all got early-stage funding not only
from the public sector but some public
funds were absolutely critical in the
case of Compaq and Intel it was SBIR in
the case of Apple it was 500k which at
the time was a
not provided by an SBIC grant just back
up here I'm terrible with slides I go
back and forth but you know again coming
back to this word revolutionary which
that economist article used you know
what makes an iPhone a revolutionary
phone it's obviously what you can do
with that phone and this is a
particularly book where I show that
every single technology which makes you
do cool things whether it's you know
searching the web through the internet
GPS knowing where you are touchscreen
display being able to use that phone in
a very easy way even on the new Siri
voice activated system which on my phone
never seems to work but apparently it's
a revolutionary technology it was all
government-funded all of it these are
the particular state agencies which you
know it's really important that when I
use the word state I'm not talking about
Big Brother you know even a ministry I'm
talking about a decentralized network of
different agencies which are absolutely
fundamental to to the outcome of these
technologies and so of course someone
like Steve Jobs was absolutely essential
and there's not enough people like him
with a sense of design of simplicity of
putting those existing technologies
together in a very cool way that's
extremely important role absolutely
fundamental we know a lot about that
there's that great biography but not one
page of that biography actually mentions
the public funding which which went into
this revolutionary new phone now often
when I talk about this in Europe they
get scared like oh my god she's talking
about the military-industrial complex
and no we don't like that right and the
point is well no you know that ended up
becoming a model the DARPA type model
that actually funded the internet we see
that type of organization that type of
funding role actually across different
departments today whether it's health or
energy this is the funding which is
absolutely astounding I think in terms
of the numbers that goes into so it's
public funding through the National
Institutes of Health which nurture a
particular area which is basically life
sciences biotech and pharma thirty two
billion a
year was spent in 2012 okay so if we're
very worried about our debt-to-gdp well
of course this does increase debt but if
this kind of funding is also fostering
growth right which is the denominator of
debt to GDP this is what's actually
needed also to reduce debt to GDP the
problem in in a country like Italy which
is where I'm from it's not that they
were spending too much in fact if you
look at the deficit level in Italy
before the crisis it was actually quite
small it was about three to four percent
less than Germany's the problem in Italy
is that for 20 years they have not been
spending on these kind of areas like R&D
and human capital formation which means
that you know the GDP growth has been
almost nil for 14 years or 15 years and
so even with a moderate deficit the debt
to GDP if the denominators is growing at
zero and the and the numerator is
growing even just a three to four
percent that ratio by definition can
almost go to infinity now what's
interesting also about this NIH funding
again coming back to the word
revolutionary is that different studies
including a great book by Marcia Angell
is called the truth behind the drug
companies shows that that funding has
been absolutely essential not just to
you know general research but actually
to the development of particular drugs
in other words their revolutionary new
molecular entities with priority rating
instead of just me to drugs slight
variations of existing drugs so it's
been fundamental to fostering change
dynamism revolutionary innovations
within this particular sector now I call
I called my book the entrepreneurial
state because entrepreneurship is not
just about setting up a company it is in
fact doing what I've been talking about
which is the ability and willingness to
engage with real risk and uncertainty
and so if you think of any sector in
terms of the technology and market risk
the point is that it's that upper right
hand quadrant which is often completely
starved of private finance and I'll show
you later a figure within the green
economy where
the upper right-hand quadrant is in fact
being funded almost exclusively today by
the public sector think of it as in
terms of you know capital intensity and
the vertical axis technological and
market risk on the on the horizontal the
upper right hand quadrant is where we
don't see business today entering in the
green space now you know one of the the
issues that the economist there was
thinking about was you know what will be
the next big general purpose technology
what's gonna be the next big change if
we think of Silicon Valley close to this
place where we're talking today some of
the big changes are in fact you know
being engineered today by companies like
Tesla Motors Tesla Motors received a 500
million guaranteed loan from the Obama
administration it's the same amount that
Solyndra received we all know about
Solyndra we don't know much well many
people don't know that Tesla also
received the exact same amount of money
when I say innovation is uncertain I
mean it's really uncertain for every
internet you have ten Conchords and
Concord is actually a bad example for a
failure because if you actually look at
all the spill overs that happened from
that a publicly funded experiment it was
actually quite successful but the plane
itself was not a success and it's often
used an example of government failing
you know trying to get too involved
picking winners and you know what I've
shown you up until now is you know Apple
was picked Compaq was picked Intel was
picked the Internet was picked GPS was
picked it's not about whether government
should be picking about how it does it
and how it also I'll argue later is able
to reap in some reward when it actually
succeeds in order precisely to fund the
losses so again looking at Green which
many of us are hoping is really going to
be the next big thing it's very
interesting to ask you know who's
funding what in that green and so yes
that's the upper right hand quadrant is
completely being starved today for
example private venture capital and
what's interesting is that it's not a
lack of money in fact the whole sort of
Finance
debate is interesting because we often
think there's sort of a lack of money
and I just mentioned before in the
private sector there's plenty of money
it's just not being spent and we also
have plenty of venture capital it's just
not you know choosing particular today
oops it's not actually engaging in some
of the more difficult areas why is this
because the venture capital model itself
is based on the exit ok you want returns
and about three to five years you want
the exit to happen in that time period
and increasingly through an IPO an
initial public offering now that's fine
for particular areas it's not fine for
the areas like clean tech like nanotech
like biotech they take fifteen to twenty
years that's the innovation cycle
fifteen to twenty years and what's
interesting and I will tell you then the
capital gains story that warren buffett
was talking about you know the reason
that capital gains fell so drastically
50 percent in six years from 1976 to so
I'm completely dehydrated because I've
been on a plane I'm very jet lag by 50
percent in six years was actually
because the National Venture Capital
Association which formed in 1976 lobbied
government extremely hard in that year
started to saying you know we're the
innovators we're the entrepreneurs
reduce our capital gains tax and we will
invest and they were very successful I
do lots of different studies of
innovation at the sectoral level and
also at the industry level and national
level and I started looking at you know
what do studies actually tell us about
that relationship between capital gains
and an investment in innovation or even
investment in general and there's no
relationship because precisely because
of what Warren Buffett was saying if you
want to invest you will invest if you
think that's a good opportunity the only
effect that capital gains tax has had in
in reducing to the level that has but
also within the capital gains tax the
particular details this actually has
been to fuel inequality in the UK when
they tried to foster a silicon
roundabout
that's what they call it in the east of
London they one of the first things they
did and this was actually a Labour
government that did it it was Gordon
Brown when he was the Treasury the head
of Treasury for Tony Blair they thought
we need venture capital right this is
the the secret to Silicon Valley and
what they did was they reduced the time
that private equity has to be invested
in order to be legible for tax
reductions from ten years to two years
okay
so when I say that venture capital is
short term it's not that it has to be
short term us by hyping up its role we
have actually in both the US and the UK
made it increasingly short term estate
at particularly rendered venture capital
more short term missed
what's interesting is that private
finance has become more short term as
for example just focusing on the exit
through the IPO in three years in the
case of venture capital what we've seen
and this is actually quite recent is the
role of particular types of public
financial institutions increase okay so
the Bloomberg New Energy Finance is a
database where you can actually look at
the entire world's public and private
types of finance in the green space and
in 2011 I remember the figure if you
took all of Private Finance in the world
so it's corporate private equity venture
capital in stock market it was 11
billion and then just a particular type
of public finance so not like Department
of Energy arpa-e type stuff just for
public banks okay so these are state
investment banks there was the German
KfW the Chinese China Development Bank
the European Investment Bank and the
Brazilian Development Bank it amounted
to 80 billion and what's interesting is
that this is new okay because it used to
be that these banks this this data here
in particular is the KfW it's a German
state investment bank these banks used
to basically do what Keynes said they
had to do where Keynes said you know the
role of the public sector
not to do what the private sector does
what does the private sector does is it
invests too much in the womb too little
in the bust
so what the public organization should
do is be counter-cyclical not
procyclical
so they used to just focus on this
countersue quality so during recessions
when private banks stopped lending the
credit crunch they would sort of kick in
and lend and they would also focus on
what we call capital development of the
economy so infrastructure projects what
we're increasingly seeing in the next
big thing is the role of these public
banks directing so digging directing
this counter cyclical loans and
disbursements into particular areas and
the green area has in fact been pretty
generally picked by the most active
banks which are basically the Brazilian
the Chinese and the German and the
European investment banks of course
other countries do have state investment
banks I'm talking about the
mission-oriented ones but the German
government and the Chinese government
have a very specific mission around
green the the China's 2020 goal in fact
is to produce 20% energy for the entire
economy from renewables and this China
Development Bank has been playing you
know a DARPA type role picking
particular types of innovative companies
including by the way hua y which is
number one today in the
telecommunications it's the number one
company even without the US market it
hasn't been allowed to enter the US
market received a massive loan from the
China Development Bank but if you look
at these figures they're absolutely
astounding you know particular companies
receiving loans and the billions and
this is why it is often accused of being
anti-competitive okay get some goes
against the competition rules which is
actually quite difficult because if it's
true and I would argue it is true and
this might be something we debate later
if it's true that private finance is
retreating from the real economy and
I'll show you a figure later also
proving it then you know and if
innovation takes a long time and doesn't
just require any type of finance but
actually requires this long-term
committed patient finance then and if
you know
is you know the way that firms actually
compete this was Schumpeter's point by
the way student Peter said that all of
neoclassical mainstream economics is
very static and it assumes that you know
something like innovation can only be
talked about in terms of imperfect
competition this would be a whole other
talk so I'm not going to go there but
the point is if in modern capitalism
skirm firms compete through innovation
if innovation requires this long term
patient committed finance and if that
type of finance is is increasingly not
found in the private sector which has
become too financialized or short-term a
speculative color what you want then
it's quite natural then that this kind
of finance will have to come out of the
DARPA types the NIH type the NSF types
the China Development type institutions
so what does this mean for competition
rules you know this is a big question
that competition authorities actually
have to grapple this the NDS this is the
Brazilian Development Bank which by the
way when I go there I go quite a bit to
Brazil because of different research
projects and I've been looking into this
bank was absolutely fascinating about
this Bank is that it's actually achieved
what DARPA has achieved in terms of
attracting talent right we often hear or
even just think of the Department of
Energy in the u.s. run by a Nobel Prize
winning physicist Steve Chu up until
recently you know as a serious brain guy
coming in bringing a level of vision
dynamism and talent which often we think
is you know not normal if you want for
public sector institution and run by a
bunch of boring bureaucrats well in
Brazil if you you know if you're a top
economist coming out of one of the
Brazilian top economics departments or
increasingly coming back to Brazil by
say Harvard economics this is one of the
best jobs you can get is actually to go
to this bank and it's a public bank it's
not a Goldman Sachs bank it's very hard
to actually do that now I don't have
time now to tell you how they've done
that but how to actually bring that kind
of talent expertise and dynamism into
these public sector institutions is the
challenge when you walk into arpa-e
which is you know trying to do in energy
what DARPA did for the Internet it's
actually pretty cool I mean it
feel at Google there's a bunch of nerdy
geeks who know lots about energy writing
on blackboards talking to each other
bringing in top scientists from places
like Norway and Denmark which by the way
are two of the countries that are
investing a lot in renewables it is a
place of experimentation where failure
is welcomed because you know that for
you know for every Tesla you will have
10 cylinders and you know this again
it's the point I won't read it but this
was a very nice quote from the global
wind energy Council where they're very
clear that you know it's what kind of
finance we need and it's increasingly
this was just a study that they
performed across the world what kind of
institutions are actually financing the
Green Revolution and they concluded that
it was these you know different types of
public sector institutions because the
private financial markets were so
short-term missed and now this is
important right because we're saying we
need these public-private partnerships
but we're often just talking about the
public side as de-risking the private
side I mean how lame is that right I
mean is that what I just described there
de-risking the private side no these are
examples in countries that have been
successful and of course the u.s. whole
Silicon Valley type model is one of the
examples that many countries around the
world are trying to copy you know this
is taking on risk right this is being
courageous setting these missions mat on
the moon green economy internet and
taking on that risk okay and attracting
because this is fundamental just said it
before but I'll repeat it now attracting
the kind of big thinkers who are willing
to engage in those missions but usually
we you know we talk just about the
public and private and this in in this
very static way now I've already
mentioned that one of the problems here
is that the private investments today
are falling we don't have I mean another
sort of provocative way to put it we do
not have in the green revolution the
kind of commitment and long term ISM
that we had in the IT revolution in the
private sector because Xerox PARC
and Bell Labs were in private companies
and they were fundamental
- the IT investments investing alongside
the state what we have today are I mean
this is a wonderful quote this is Bill
Gates you know who is one of the seven
CEOs in this American energy industry
Council and you know Bill Gates is a
smart guy he doesn't say you know he he
doesn't say government get out of the
way you're a big metal or he's a very
specific here he's saying hey government
is important in fact you know what we
follow the private sector follows after
the government has taken on the big risk
he's very specific here though notice
he's saying basic research and I've just
tried to convince to at least that in
fact these government investments were
along the entire innovation chain but
we'll forgive him just for that little
error but the problem is you know as I
said then American energy industry
Council of seven companies and because I
sometimes have fun with thinking about
these issues I started doing some
calculations with a colleague of mine
bill a zonic we calculated how much
those seven companies that are
represented in the American energy
industry Council have been themselves
investing in this big green race because
what they were asking for or are asking
for is actually something that I think
is very valid no we shouldn't cut back
government we need more government and
how much we want government to be doing
the arpa-e type projects and they asked
government to spend 16 billion more a
year in clean tech and to give
additional 1 billion to arpa-e you know
it's very visionary but themselves were
not actually Co investing and again you
know where are the Xerox parks in that
space and why is this a problem and this
is the financialization I was mentioning
before because these share buybacks okay
what they are is is focusing on boosting
stock prices boosting stock options to
boost executive pay in the end if you
ask companies in fact let me get to
second for someone I tell you what's on
the screen this is a proxy for when
people say we are to financialized what
do they mean they mean that the pace at
which the financial sector has grown has
completely well outpaced the real
economy this data here is for
the UK for the US that's even worse but
I just wanted to show you that you know
you're not alone in this problem this is
showing you that financial
intermediation I can barely see it as a
percentage of gross value added has
outpaced the real economy which was
basically that black line everything but
finance and agriculture and this is by
the way one of the reasons that
industrial policy is back because then
policymakers say we have to rebalance
away from finance away from these
terrible derivatives credit default
swaps hedge funds towards the real
economy right so towards Life Sciences
IT the creative sector what they don't
realize is just how financialized the
real economy itself has become right so
this is one of the points of in making
which is the private part of the
public-private partnerships has not been
investing big time as it used to this
you should worry about the black line
there that's showing you the amount of
repurchases so buybacks to R&D spending
okay so many companies I shouldn't name
them but I have a feeling that my next
slide I do name them I might have to go
quickly because I'm not sure who your
sponsors are have been spending things
you know a particular company have in
mind has spent more money in biotech on
buybacks in R&D in every single year for
the last decade except 2004 the total
amount of buybacks that the Fortune 500
companies have spent in the last decade
three trillion when you ask these
companies why are you doing that why
aren't you spending an R&D why aren't
you spending on human capital formation
they say cuz there's no opportunities
this is the right thing to do you know
when there's no opportunities for
investment that you know giving back the
money to the shareholders is the right
thing to do you then look at the those
sectors where this phenomena is the
worst or health and oil there's no
opportunities and renewables there's no
opportunities and you know worldwide
diseases hmm we just showed before who's
actually spending in those areas and
this is not public vs. private this is
not what I'm saying I'm not saying good
guy bad guy yeah I'm saying this is part
of the debate that we should be having
to have that kind of smart innovation
led growth
what kind of companies do we actually
need to be investing alongside the state
and why is it that we always have to
justify any type of state intervention
instead of actually trying to justify
public policy which is going to try to
foster also more of the Xerox PARC type
investments and not allow here let me go
quickly over that one because I did
realize I recently gave a talk and I had
all the names of the sponsors and
afterwards they were like we're gonna
have to take that off of your slides
later and I think this will be easier
for you no I'm kidding I'm kidding I'm
kidding okay look go back okay good
by the way Apple is is really
interesting because under Steve Jobs
Apple did no share buybacks okay when
you look at a particular sector that I
was getting to at the beginning when I
said markets or outcomes if you look at
telecommunications as I mentioned before
Huawei number one no share buybacks
Ericsson number two no share buybacks
Cisco massive share buybacks okay these
are choices that companies have to make
a pharma and biotech are extremely
problematic but as I showed you before
also the emerging clean tech space is
also very problematic now why is this
important and why did I have on my first
slide this whole thing about value
creation and and value extraction well
one of my key points is that by
completely dismissing and not talking
about the role of the public sector and
by that I mean the tax payers that are
in fact funding all these different
agencies the DARPA zarba is NSF SBIR s
in the US but in these other countries
for example the state investment banks
by not talking and admitting the role
that the public sector plays in this
entrepreneurial knowledge-based economy
we have in fact socialized the risks but
privatized the rewards you know Google's
algorithm funded by NSF we know how much
Google pays back tax to the cut to the
government Apple it's been in the in the
headlines right Amazon these are
companies that have a benefited
extremely not just from the roads not
just from the educated workforce but
specifically from government taking on
mass
risks in particular technologies that
their profits today are riding on and of
course these companies themselves have
done amazing things as the example I
gave of Steve Jobs but if it's true
if it's true that the government played
a pivotal role in fostering these
technologies through its ability to
think in a long run way
then who's gonna fund the next round
right do you know what tax was the
marginal income tax was under Eisenhower
who was not a communist yeah like that
well close to 90 yeah I mean this was a
Republican General now I'm not of course
advocating that we should go back
advocating that we should go back to
that kind of tax rate but the point is
how those top rates tax rates fell how
capital gains tax fell it actually
co-evolved with a discourse and
narrative about who the innovators were
who the entrepreneurs were who was
fundamental for the knowledge economy
and in fact those reductions in tax
today and I don't want to talk so much
about the rate of the tax because that's
not the point but this discussion about
government way and do things like R&D
tax credits is it's not evidence driven
I've studied a lot these R&D tax credits
there's almost no additionality in other
words they don't make R&D happen that
would not have happened anyway they do
have an effect in countries like the US
where you do have these huge public
funds which are then driving the
investment so they are D Tax reddit is
like icing on the cake but they don't
make the R&D happen okay and this is
also a big problem in Europe by the way
where we're reducing we don't have
public labs anymore
they've all been destroyed and then we
do you know engage with these R&D tax
credits and venture capital thinking
that big things are gonna happen and
then scratch our heads and you know why
didn't it
but quickly because I don't want to take
up too much time yeah I need to finish
in about five minutes you know this this
whole risk/reward thing has become sort
of front page right front page also in
the streets this issue about the 1% the
99% this graph here just shows you again
it ain't a finance problem there's
plenty of profits out there there's
record level profits in fact and how
a very nice way also to think about it
because you can calculate GDP in
different ways demand product but also
income and if we look at income parts
you know the profit to wage ratio has
just gone off the charts especially if
you look at it over the last hundred
years
um now the explanation that we usually
hear about this in terms of you know
innovation inequality some people being
left behind yes profits are soaring but
that's because hey some people have some
great ideas and they're making profits
from that and others
yes workers are you know fundamental for
the production process but those who
don't have the right skills or getting
left behind and hooked so that's
fostered a very important in fact
discussion about retraining and how to
allow those left behind to catch up
however is that really what's driving
you know that difference is it perhaps
something else I mean I would argue that
the skills problem which technically
economists talk about this in terms of
the skill bias of technical change
explains sort of the middle problem
right so the the the problems that we
have in achieving middle class type jobs
that are of the type that we used to
have it I want to go into the the skills
problem because it is quite complex but
the one percent 99 percent problem the
fact that something like 50 percent of
the gains and the IT revolution era have
gone to the one percent is that because
of skills what I would argue is that in
fact it's about value extraction and one
of the really interesting facts about
innovation right by people who actually
study innovation so it's a collective
process it's very uncertain it's not
just risky but it's also cumulative okay
so people like Brian Arthur and Paul
David have talked about innovation in
terms of it being path dependent okay
innovation is persistent innovation
today depends on innovation yesterday
it's cumulative and what we have is in
fact because we haven't had
right story about who is actually
contributing to the process we've
actually allowed particular types of
agents including large venture capital
companies to enter late sort of think
you know this is time on the horizontal
axis halfway through and reap not just
their marginal contribution ok the
rewards compared to the actual risk they
took but actually reap the entire
integral underneath that curve now what
to do okay well there's all sorts of
things one could do and I don't want to
advocate any one particular measure in
fact you need a lot of lawyers in the
room to do that but we haven't even had
the debate okay I mean are taxes enough
forget even just the fact that they've
been falling and that we don't have the
right and necessarily I would say
political atmosphere today to even talk
about tax so let's just forget tax let's
just assume that it's it is being
collected okay everyone's paying their
tax it's that really the way that
government would be able to reap back
its reward in a situation where again
for every Tesla you have ten cylinders
that's a massive failure rate right in
venture capital has it also venture
capital investments something like nine
out of ten fail but the one winning
investment right so for kleiner perkins
that Genentech investment more than
covers the losses and also covers the
next round we don't have that for
government why because we have an
admitted that it's a venture capitalist
by the way if you look around the world
there are some countries where this
venture capital role of government is is
much more obvious in one of these is
Israel um but in the US you know one of
the funds has actually come out of the
CIA through Inc you tell you guys
probably know that because you're you
think a lot about innovation in this
area but you know most people in the US
would be like what you know CIA doing
public metrocapital well yes in fact the
touchscreen display investment also
before that I mentioned was also funded
by the CIA not through think you tell
them anyway you know why not retain some
equity Sitra public funding agency in
finland that invested in early stage
Nokia did
retain equity and made a lot of money
from that investment which then funded
the next round the fact that the Nokia
you know has not been too smart and
reacting to the smartphone that's that's
a different problem it's not because of
you know received that money but the
state and investment banks for example
what's very interesting is they
obviously retain equity because there
are investment banks but we also have a
real issue with the patent system the
IPR system we have the bae dole act
which was a good
I think policy which in 1980 allowed
publicly funded research to be patented
which it couldn't be before that this
was a measure that was thought up in
order to enable more commercialization
get science out of universities and
actually into producing products that in
fact fostered the whole biotech
revolution because many of these patents
actually then became spin outs but
there's a there's if you actually read
that act it's a very big act it actually
says in there but of course we have to
make sure the taxpayer doesn't pay twice
right that'd be kind of stupid so one
way to do that would be actually to
allow government to have a say on the
prices it's never executed that right
and I think also the reason is because
of this this again this discourse we
have right if the role of government is
just to foster innovation and the
private sector create those conditions
and then allow these revolutionaries to
do their things and what right do you
have to sort of you know talk about
prices it should be these innovative
companies that set their prices to
recoup their costs
well increasingly in fact if you go to
some of these big conferences at the
Financial Times organizes for the
pharmaceutical industry they are very
outrightly saying we're gonna close down
or big R&D labs and our private
companies because in fact the open
innovation system is allowing us more
and more to get the sort of niche
radical ideas either out of these small
biotech companies or when they're honest
out of this big NIH funding in fact
Pfizer recently closed a plant and
sangwich Kent and moved to Boston not
because of lower tax or lower regulation
but because of that NIH funding anyway
they're saying quite openly that they're
gonna close down these R&D labs but the
discourse is all about this open
innovation system but of course the
pricing policies have very much been
they
based on the fact that the are part of
rnd is so uncertain so one question
would be as you are outsourcing
increasingly that are to the public
sector then how much you know how much
uncertainty do you really have to
actually be still charging these you
know absolutely very high prices which
make the taxpayers that funded their
research not even be able to afford it
even in countries with a welfare state
it's still the state that then funds the
welfare state so it's still paying twice
yeah so income contingent loans we do it
for students why not for companies and
you know how again to do this it's very
complicated but hey if you can send a
man or a woman to the moon we can figure
this stuff out you know Google again
this grant that was given to the two
Google guys who then you know that ended
up with the algorithm that sorry the
grant resulted in the algorithm behind
Google there still could be something
even in those grants that says you know
what this is just a grant do your thing
but if it results in something that
leads to X billion then over time
something will come back to let's call
it an Innovation Fund to fund the next
round now
again I'm putting in a very simplistic
way of course it'll be easy to find a
fault with how he just said it but the
point is let's have that conversation
and of course by having that
conversation not only will we make sure
that we get a sustainable cycle where
for example the profits from the
internet can then fund the next big
thing which might be green which instead
today we have a serious budgetary
problems in these organizations that are
supposed to be funding the next big
round this editorial piece that came out
today in the New York Times for my book
I was very happy to see it I wasn't
expecting it in fact talked about the
huge cuts that are being made to the
public research system in the US and the
name of you know reducing the deficit
and keeping things tight in order to
foster growth you know austerity is
gonna help us you know overcome the
crisis by smelling down a government
that has actually resulted in a forty
billion reduction in public R&D funding
so but it's also going to potentially
make this growth more inclusive okay not
just smart not just more sustainable
also inclusive there's been you know
lots to talk about the public school
system in Silicon Valley you know how
wrong is that that a place that receives
so much direct funding both for the
companies and the technologies hasn't
resulted in a more equitable and
inclusive public education system now
when I say it's a discursive battle by
the way there's another great book by
tony guts i don't know if you've heard
of him the book was ill fares the land
he actually says he says let's look at
the last kind of 40 years of the way we
talk about the state and how that's
co-evolved with kind of you know bashing
away at the notion of the welfare state
and he talks about this also globally
and he says you know all of a sudden in
the 1970s this word administration pops
up that didn't actually exist before to
describe what government does and you
know he just has it there in a little
line of a particular paragraph but to me
it just completely jumped out I mean how
boring is that who would want to go work
in the government if that's all
government is doing regulate regulating
administering meddling right so actually
how we talk about this state completely
then affects the kind of people and
talent and dynamism and ability to think
big in this missionary way or missionary
sounds bad mission way and and I'm not
gonna go into all these words but you
might have heard of some of them right I
mean crowding and crowding out we often
hear that government when it gets to
activist crowding out private finance
but within these particular areas I've
been looking at you know whether it's
green or IT in the beginning of IT what
the government did was not even just
crowd in which is the usual Keynesian
defense of what government's doing which
means that when you have underutilized
capacity if you have government
investing through the multiplier effect
that increases GDP so what you're
actually doing is increasing the amount
of total funds both for public and
private right that's the usual Keynesian
defense of why you need government to to
actually invest in times like this and a
recession
what I've just described before in these
different areas is government doing much
more than just crowding in and it's
actually investing in new areas in
frontier areas which create a new space
which is kind of like I mean there's no
word for it I just call it dynamize
again but the fact that we don't have a
word for it actually also then affects
how we evaluate the you know how we
measure the performance of these
investments we actually don't have
indicators that can describe to us what
government did so it's much easier in
fact to come up with this kind of
crowding out type analysis I see this
even by the way with other types of
organizations like the BBC which is a
public broadcaster in the UK which also
gets accused of crowding out private
broadcasting because it has such a big
share the quality of BBC programmes I
don't know if you've ever watched them
but it's pretty high but what's
interesting in lots of these economic
analyses of the BBC and its potential
crowding out of the private broadcasters
the the Economist writing the in this
case an actual economist not the act The
Economist magazine they will say but of
course you know we're economists we you
know we can't have a normative or
subjective interpretation of the quality
of the program so we're just gonna keep
quality constant right and so you know
Skyy Rupert Murdoch or whatever you know
we're gonna assume that the quality is
just something we can't measure now it
that's really problematic and I also see
it in more technical studies up for
example private and public venture
capital comparing the returns
completely dismissing and not looking at
the very different risk space that the
public venture capital in these cases
that I'm thinking of these were
Scandinavian public venture capital
funds were investing in a very different
risk landscape with much higher
uncertainty that should that compare the
returns if you don't have a measure for
that you're gonna bias it from the start
against these public investments
de-risking I've already said let's
change that word you share the risks and
hence you share the rewards and again
that will affect how we attract these
you know the best and brightest because
it becomes a self-fulfilling prophecy
the more you just talk about the state
at best
fixing a market failure you know the
the more you're actually the also
affecting the kind of person that wants
to go into that particular organization
if you are someone who wants to think
big and and experiment and feel part of
an institution that is really raising
the stakes and doing frontier stuff and
all you're doing is fixing market
failures that actually might affect your
choice of where to go of course it's
going to be more exciting to go work in
Google and Goldman Sachs than it is to
go work for a public ministry and some
country and by the way this is a big
problem in Europe where we're constantly
asking ourselves God why can't we do our
Silicon Valley kind of thing and you
know why are all these great companies
coming out of the u.s. the answer has
been because they haven't had this sort
of analysis of understanding that
venture capital surfed a wave of state
investments the answer has been we have
to increase the market and reduce the
state and that is completely what we're
witnessing today it's not just since the
crisis if you look at the innovation
discourse in Europe it's about in order
to have the silicon valley's we need to
reduce the size of the public sector we
need to foster you know early stage seed
finance and so this huge as I've already
said rise of all these different types
of venture capital funds and tax
policies to foster that kind of funds
and then what's interesting I don't know
if you know this terrible word pigs I'm
allowed to say because I'm Italian right
if if I was a German this wouldn't be
good right because you know the Italy
Greece Spain Portugal they're pigs this
is what Goldman Sachs that it was just
literally the words then we actually
increased it to Ireland as well so it's
no longer the pigs which is a bit less
politically incorrect but these are the
weak these are the weak eurozone
countries okay and as you know we often
think oh god you know they they are you
know holding things down the German
wallet is going to be financing them
during the bailout so what we don't say
is that you know these countries that's
not that they were spending too much
they were spending very badly again the
German deficit was actually higher than
than the Italian deficit but if these
countries the pigs are not spending an
rnd on Hugh
and capital formation on education but
also setting up these particular types
of funding cycles that I've been talking
about which are able to foster these new
innovations then you know that's why you
have this completely skewed
competitiveness in Europe and we don't
say that what they should be doing is
for example what the Germans did which
was not tightening their belt it was
actually spending on the KfW this state
investment bank
Fraunhofer Institute's which are these
science industry links that are fostered
in these institutions called the
Fraunhofer Institute's very well-funded
very high R&D to GDP but also directed
towards these big missions like green we
don't hear that that's not the medicine
that were you know that's not the
analysis the diagnosis hence it's also
not in the medicine and what we have
today is countries like Spain having cut
their publicly funded R&D spending by 40
percent since 2009 in order to meet
these new fiscal compact criteria this
is not only about for Europe is of
course also bad for the u.s. because
this European crisis will which will
continue as long as you had this very
different competitiveness levels will
create a crisis because you can't have
one currency for an area that has such
different levels of competitiveness
I really should wrap up and I'll just
say think again
[Applause]
have a seat over there the question is
you were talking things served
historically because you've looked at
mmm US and Europe over the past number
of decades and I noticed I was around
for some of the early ARPA when it was
our patent on DARPA Advanced Research
Projects Agency in Department of Defense
later limited to DARPA defense a lot so
it could be completely innovative then
and that was a outgrowth of first the
war in the eyes and our ears and all
that and then the Cold War and in space
race and all that sort of thing and the
information technology sector that they
were that pushing then you know created
basically computers time sharing our
power which became ARPANET that which
became Internet which became the world
there was a war
framing there and you Herman Kahn used
to say one thing you really need a
nation for is a war and this is one of
the reasons it's nations kind of like
Wars because they justify themselves but
that's backing off and the Cold War died
down the peace dividend it sounds like
part of what you're describing is the
peace dividend we didn't need the nation
to defend us from these great big
security things anymore so let's just go
count on the private sector doing all
the fun stuff is that anyway the a sense
of what you see has happened and if so
sue me we don't want a war do you crank
up the belief in government again is
that the narrative rethink that you want
I think there's two issues the first is
that looking again for example in this
green space those countries like Germany
and China that are investing massively
have actually framed it as a
or we have you know climate change is a
war there's a war to be made had also if
you read the National Institute of
Health website they they talked about as
a mission now they don't phrase it as a
war but and of course in the u.s. there
is a initial so with the healthcare
system which is obviously different from
the health care products that's very
interesting debate the degree to which
those countries that are the most
innovative in the healthcare products
are or are not also innovative in the
system which which actually then breaks
the drugs to the people but you know if
you read that website it's it's very
it's very serious right I mean there's a
mission around health care so the
question is how governments I mean I'm
thinking of it almost from the other
side think strategically and say if we
want to fund this stuff we actually have
to create a narrative around security
interests right you know we need to
invest in energy in order to maintain
national security of our energy but if
you read you know the in between the
lines has talked about as a war but I
would say in other words youth
unemployment you know the aging crisis
the Democratic crisis we have today in
many countries which is putting at risk
you know the kind of pension systems
that people have relied on that can be
phrased in terms of war in terms of a
battle a big battle and I think what I
was trying to say at the beginning is
that these are big missions big battles
which actually require then the
government agencies that are investing
to see themselves I don't I say at war
but part of a big battle and instead the
narrative which has occurred which I
don't think has been necessarily how you
mentioned but I think it's actually been
very ideological there's been lots of
profits been made from this particular
narrative right there only some or the
innovators and others are just kind of
they're either lazy or at best fixing
conditions that narrative has made it
much more difficult for government to
present itself as a creator and an
investor in these missions and then the
question is why has it become so
profitable you know
whether we talk about deregulation but
again I don't want to steer the
conversation too far away from your
question but there have been particular
policies which have made it easier so I
should look at you guys have been making
value extraction activities rewarded
over value creation activities I know
that sounds really abstract but that's
basically what we've had for the last 20
years and that has I think come out of
policies which have been driven by a
very narrow understanding of who the
value creators are and again the
National mentor Capital Association was
very explicit they said we are the value
creators reduce our tax it wasn't just
saying you know this is good for the
we're the universities fit in this story
they're not exactly government and they
aren't businesses but a lot of the are
and be of great consequence goes on
there so what's their role here well
they've a huge role but it's it's very
important to be specific on what that
role is so and sorry if I keep talking
about Europe but hey I lived there so I
also see lots of mistakes that are made
there but in trying to copy the u.s.
system what they're doing in Europe is
making universities increasingly like
businesses and they don't get that
actually what was very successful about
the u.s. system was that you had and I
know it's also changing here but I think
in a less drastic way you had very high
level blueSky properly funded research
done in universities an early stage
technology development done in companies
then this you know big notion that
somehow the problem is commercialization
and technology transfer and that's the
big thing that's missing has has turned
lots of universities into these kind of
technology transfer offices which in
Europe at least is also being how do you
say specified in terms of also creating
spinouts right so Cambridge University
is you know trying to create spin outs
there was no spin out policy in
California spin outs happened naturally
at a very well funded research system
in the Universities and so actually
better understanding the division of
innovative labor between universities
companies and of course the linkages
between them is actually quite difficult
and it's not enough to say universities
are important because in fact you can
get a very dysfunctional university
system by not actually again you know
talking about it in a very particular
way and again even though in the u.s.
you have lots of private universities
and in Europe all universities are
public basically so Cambridge and Oxford
are state they're public universities
but in in the u.s. many private
universities of course like MIT are
massively funded by the private sector
sorry public sector and so and so just
the notion you know when you say
universities aren't really public
actually if you look at the sort of big
science and places like Harvard MIT and
another important universities in
Stanford there's a interesting one from
David Eckler it says global this global
business can invest in produce in a way
that addressed international
opportunities they you know
international corporations or
international governments generally
don't do that you're focusing on
governments very much
Arthur means by which governments might
join together especially on global
issues like climate change that have a
that they can in its sense think and act
globally the way some multinational
corporations can think and act wholly
yeah well I think I mean again if you
think of the only public lab left in
Europe practically CERN it's it's
international its European wide at least
and it came out with HTML you know the
language used by the web and these these
public funding agencies in the green
area they are national in terms of the
actual agency so the China Development
Bank is Chinese
but the investments is making our global
so it's not just about international
organizations collaborating but also
particularly active national
organizations that see
the global climate change problem as a
global one it's very interesting how
they're seeing their own investments as
global investments by the way what's
also very interesting is that those few
countries because it's a handful it's a
handful that do this mission oriented
stuff it's not States so I'm not talking
about government talking about
particular countries that have had
mission oriented state agencies it's
very interesting to see how they also
tend to see other countries not as
threats but opportunities so Denmark
which is one of the most active in both
wind and solar has become the number one
provider of high-tech services so
they're they're not just you know doing
the products also the services to
China's green economy and China spending
1.7 trillion on this economy so a small
country like Denmark which has sort of
been very active and innovative in that
green space is benefiting from the
Chinese investments this is I suppose an
advantage there being a lots of
different nations that some nations like
Denmark can bear down and specialize and
sort of become the market leader
worldwide in that domain is that part of
how the international system plays out
here the nations are essentially
competing in each finding their nation
and jamming ahead to lead that niche
yeah I mean don't forget the innovation
another sort of aspect of that I mean I
mentioned you know there's collective
it's uncertain it's also path dependent
it's also very you know another aspect
of the capaz de pendency it's not just
this cumulative aspect but also that you
know let me just give you an example
carpets there's this wonderful story
that Paul Krugman tells in a book he
wrote called pedaling prosperity carpets
when they started to be made and I don't
know anything about carpets I'm just
remembering the words he used in a
tufted way don't ask me
wasn't the in the middle of the 18th
century and all of a sudden they all
started being made in this place called
Dalton Georgia and are still today
something like 80% of carpet production
is made there why because there was this
pool of labour of these young girls who
knew how to make tufted bedspreads and
during when they would have birthdays
they would give each other these
bedspreads and when carpet started to be
made with this tufted technique because
that labor pool knowledgeable pool of
Labor was already there somehow people
figured it out but the carpet people and
proved and started producing them there
and it's still today it it has this
niche and that's because there's very
strong sort of dynamic returns to scale
in other words because it started there
then all the innovation ended up
happening there but the same thing you
can say about the internal combustion
engine it wasn't a you know ex-ante the
the best engine there was four or five
different engines it by chance got a
little bit of a head start and then all
the innovation started to occur around
that particular engine so later it did
become better than the other ones but
that's because of the dynamic so it's
the same thing with with countries
Germany almost by chance started to
specialize in machine tools and it's
still today the most competitive in the
world in that area so you have these
very strong sort of path-dependent
dynamics which are both good and bad I
mean the fact we still have an internal
combustion engine
today in our cars is because we also get
locked into right these technologies
that's also the example people often
give of you know the keyboards the fact
that we're still using today the QWERTY
keyboard is completely mad anyway do
people know this story but it's the same
thing with countries the point is that
these initial advantages because
innovation is so cumulative and path
dependent it's actually very
advantageous to get the first mover
advantage so the fact that Denmark
Germany you know made those investments
they still are today to the most
competitive in these areas even though
one of the issues is it should be a
portfolio of investments if you just
choose wins you're going to be extremely
susceptible to changes there still
advantages being a big country versus a
small country either way well yeah I
mean Denmark is a very small country the
u.s. obviously is they only have six
people to agree to take over that nation
I think the biggest difference between
countries is not the size I mean again
just think of you know Singapore or you
know take Finland Finland was actually a
pretty basket case country up until the
mid 80s and then it made a very explicit
decision to become an innovative country
and invested massively increased its
investments in education R&D it
developed agencies like Sitra Israel the
same you know I don't wanna say
overnight but these were decisions of
you know we want to be innovative we
have to set up these kinds of agencies
which will foster so that's a question
from Alex are there countries that are
doing a great job of this kind of
balance you're talking about you
mentioned Denmark Israel and others in
are they are they paying attention to
each other the way businesses pay very
close attention to each other and you
know watch what's actually working is
that the case here I think so
so I mean with for example these state
investment banks I know there's lots of
conversations between the Chinese the
Germans and the Brazilians in terms of
how they are operating but I think it's
helped see more about that those
conversations occurs this conferences or
visiting each other's joint investments
so you know in this global wind energy
report that I mentioned and in both wind
and solar they often do make joint
investments and in different areas and
these aren't just sort of isolated
projects but I was at a conference
recently in Brazil where they had the
members of all the different state
investment banks around the world
they're talking you know there is a
they're trying to foster learning but I
think one of the most interesting
learning processes is organizationally
so I know that you know the some of the
Scandinavian countries were very
interested in how DARPA was set up in
terms of these kind of you know
five-year Sakana
you you don't call it second menhir what
do you call it when you leave one job
but you hold your place and go work in
DARPA for five years that kind of
organization Knoll innovation if you
want was done so that you would get
people coming in to DARPA RBE today and
again welcoming failure because their
time there was gonna be for four or five
years they weren't seeing it as a
lifetime job and so they were able to
sort of engage and and experiment and do
the whole trial and error thing in a
public sector organization I know that
these types organizations like Sitra or
like the TSP in the UK have looked very
closely at the DARPA model beyond just
you know funding innovation it was an
organizational innovation as well and I
think that's one of the biggest
challenges for these public sector
organizations to learn from the
organizational aspect so that you don't
get inertial into bureaucratic which is
just a cartoon image you mentioned Paul
Krugman around ago sort of approvingly
and it makes me wonder who are the
economists that you pay closest
attention to out there besides your
immediate and colleagues well one of the
issues and I don't want to pick on sort
of Krugman or Stiglitz but I think what
one of the very interesting would thing
with these economists that today are
very active in the public debate is they
don't have any theory of the state in
the boom so often in the you know for
example in TV shows when there they have
maybe a journalist who's trying to
provoke them they say okay so you're
saying that government should be counter
cyclical but where were you in the boom
then you know telling government to
retract and they have nothing to say
because they have a purely Keynesian
view or at least hope they have
interpreted Keynes which is that
government should be counter cyclical
and yet all the investments that led to
the internet we're done in the boom so
this issue of directionality you know
that government is there when it's
thinking big when it's able to think up
missions where it's not just playing
this counter-cyclical role but actually
making decisions about where these
investments should go is actually quite
important and and you know you used to
really see this today I mean how much
quantitative easing did we have did that
really cause growth no because it
actually wasn't you know where did it
end up in bank coffers not being lent so
it's not just about creation of money or
you know Keynes also had this quote
where he says just dig ditches and
fill him up again well he said it out of
desperation because in and he was right
when he said it you know just get
anything going but it doesn't work
actually in the long run
you can't just a dig a ditch and fill it
up again you have to decide what kind of
roads what kind of bridges do we
actually want and that directionality is
often what we fear we think that's
government getting too active picking
winners but let me just say one thing
which i think is really important cuz
when I say green I'm not just talking
about wind and solar and biofuels I'm
also talking about that but I'm actually
talking about the transformation of the
entire economy and this was really
important because mass production or
electrification which are also other big
general purpose technologies they took
kind of like 40 to 50 years to get fully
deployed throughout the entire economy
and today if you look at the IT
revolution and compare it to electricity
we're just halfway there you know IT has
not been fully deployed and one way that
I understand green and I really learned
a lot from a colleague of mine called
cut off the bet as a very important
historian is that green could be
actually a redirection of the entire
economy so that for IT to be fully
deployed and and what I mean by that
what I mean by that is suburbanization
was a way that the mass production
revolution got fully deployed and
suburbanization didn't just happen out
of anywhere it's not that people just
woke up and said oh I'm gonna go live in
the suburbs
I want a washing machine it was an
outcome of policy policy public policy
made suburbanization happen and it's not
that suburbanization was good or bad the
point is it was a policy to allow mass
production to get fully deployed so the
big question today is not state or no
stay private or public is what you know
what kind of growth do we want you know
the whole smart inclusive thing but also
how to steer you know IT can go in
anyway you know is it just another
gadget we want or is it really a
transformation of the economy in a
direction that we want and like it or
not it's only gonna happen with strong
public policy guiding it in that
direction and Green is a pretty good
choice what do you mean by Green yeah
well okay this then the guy who claps
should respond
okay I mean everything I mean things
like even thinking about you know
product obsolescence
you know how long products last
currently the way we think of product
obsolescence in other words that you buy
something you throw it away after five
years well it's not very green but it
also also it also emerged from a notion
that markets are limited right that you
only have so many middle-class people
and those are the people buying these
gadgets or washing machines and so you
know in order to expand your production
you're gonna have to make sure that they
kind of fall apart after a while and as
you have an expanding middle class all
over the world in fact rapidly expanding
and some people also see this is
problematic for green in fact that could
potentially change how we even think of
product obsolescence it's no longer true
we have limited markets markets are
expanding and it should even affect how
we think of that yeah but also I mean
things like recycling it's pretty low
low tech right I mean you really could
get the whole recycling area much more
high-tech and allow IT into that space
but also maintenance of products right I
mean if we did have longer product
obsolescence cycle the whole maintenance
area first of all could become
job-creating area right so we don't have
this trade-off of green versus jobs but
but maintenance not just you know fixing
a car when it breaks down but again you
know really thinking of it in a
high-tech kind of way I mean I'm just
saying it actually could affect
everything of course green is also I
think a portfolio of energy choices and
you know it's quite interesting that
fracking and shale forget what you think
about it in terms of the danger all this
talk about you know that it produces
these potential earthquakes and
underground it was a hundred percent
state-funded if you're interested in
this the breakthrough Institute's come
out with a great report on the history
of fracking but you know that's I think
the danger fracking is simply that it's
limited the portfolio energy investments
renewable energy investments by the
current administration has completely
been reduced since the shale
obsession not so much revolution because
in fact it's been going
for for many years if you read that
report so this limitation of the
portfolio of renewables I think is a
huge problem because as soon as shale
and you know that type of gas doesn't
happen anymore if we haven't been
investing in renewables at the rate that
we were before and precisely because
innovation is path-dependent creasing
dynamic returns to scale we're gonna be
in a mess policy tends to sort of
oscillate over time everybody doing X
for a while and then it's something else
becomes a big deal and that tapers off
and then they are doing X again it's a
new version of X is that kind of thing
going on in this sort of public
investment in R&D
so is it was down now and some important
respects like he said the NIH budgets
are you know we're basically peaked and
it not kind of dropped off a bit does
that mean it's gonna drop off and
disappear or is your sense that people
assert from those hoops we went too far
in this direction that we're gonna
correct and you're part of that
correction actually weird a very unique
moment you know what we've seen around
the world which is complete count
procyclical government is unique it's it
actually hasn't happened since World War
two mm-hm
so you know whether it's because of
ideology or whatever let's just just say
actually it's what's happened so
governments retreating during recessions
which is what's making these public
budgets then go down in this particular
space is is is something we have a
witnessed the NIH spending and the
spending for the different areas
underneath the Department of Defense
including DARPA has not undergone sort
of big cuts in fact even you know Reagan
and who during the Thatcher era was
someone who very actively proposed that
we should have limited smaller
government he didn't reduce the funding
of these particular agencies it's
actually increased under Reagan so while
there were massive cuts to state
spending around let's just call it the
welfare state type
yeah actually in this innovation space
they haven't been cut and today they're
being cut because you just have this
mass sort of austerity mentality where
you know if someone like Obama has tried
to resist but hasn't been successful in
resisting it and you know don't forget
that we didn't have counter cyclical
government before World War two and the
way you see this by the way is the
Consumer Price Index you complicate I'll
just tell you quickly cuz it's
fascinating if you plot prices from 1800
to 1950
so through price indices you often had
deflation so the price of you know an
object was actually lower in nominal
terms than it was say the year before
only once government started to do what
Keynes said which was to actually you
know enter the game seriously did you
start having two things one no more
depressions there was depressions every
kind of 10 to 15 years depressions not
recessions you guys and myself are used
to recessions happening kind of 10 to 15
years completely eliminated depressions
up until recently this last crisis
because you had this worldwide cut back
together in government spending but also
prices all of a sudden mildly rising and
as long as you have a low rate of
inflation it's okay
in fact it's a sign of growth of stable
growth it's only when you have really
unstable growth so depressions happen in
kind of every time to 15 years that's
when you have this persistent kind of
deflationary periods but the big point
is that actually this Keynesian stuff
worked in terms of preventing
depressions because the reason you get a
depression is that when you get a
recession that's when consumers are
spending less and companies are spending
less if on top of that government is
also spending less then you know it
becomes a vicious cycle so what you need
is that counter cyclical allottee which
actually worked
now whether then you have too much of it
etc that's another problem but the fact
that all of a sudden since this
particular crisis is 2007 you had
governments around the world being
procyclical has just been a disaster
has affected the spending and they learn
to listen and do better next time and
thanks to you we hope right a couple of
questions about China and the young me
I've been trying to come up a lot Mary
Kay Majesty is the Chinese government is
putting many billions of dollars into
trying encourage innovation but isn't
yet getting the results it wants to see
what's the balance that you think is nee
between government funding and other
factors to encourage innovation and
Kevin Kelley asks do you think China
today is doing a better job with the
entrepreneurial state and how do the
Chinese respond to your thesis so when I
recently was in China gave a
presentation at some ministry called
most Ministry of Science and Technology
and I gave them you know something
similar and they said so I don't get it
you know why so why is a ysus story not
known I mean of course the Industrial
might of the US we know was you know
fundamentally a result of this kind of
spending how can it be that people don't
know that and that then there's you know
not that kind of discussion and you know
that's what there was they were very
interested in I mean you know they even
said how can it be that people say
government medals in the healthcare area
when actually what you're saying is
government created the drugs you know
government as part of the innovation
system and so they were very interested
in the lack of public knowledge if you
want of the role that government has
played but what's interesting in China
the challenge in China is that how
they're doing it is very top-down it's
very much kind of ministry led it's very
much you know again the China
Development Bank playing a massive role
so if it's true again biggis that this
stuff is more successful when it's kind
of this decentralized network of public
and private agencies interacting
together in a dynamic well-funded way
what does it mean for that ecosystem
which currently is still quite top-down
because don't forget that you know
spending on R&D is not enough in spite
the in China and China has increased it
by 170 percent over the last five years
its amount of spending on rnd we know
lots if you look at Japan and the USSR
or sorry the X Soviet Union Japan was
spending
less than the Soviet Union on R&D they
were spending quite a bit but less much
less actually their R&D to GDP ratio was
hovering more around 2% and the Soviet
Union's around 3.5 and yet Japan grew
much more why because it had these
horizontal linkages that has what we
call today system of innovation where
this new sort of knowledge information
science actually could get properly
diffused throughout the economy because
of these science industry links also
because companies themselves had these
horizontal kind of teamwork type
structures but especially between the
institutions there was there was lots of
dynamic linkages whereas the Soviet
Union was very top-down and very defense
led so there was a very little
innovation you know distributed
throughout their economy but the fact
that they didn't have the science
industry linkages that within companies
you know the the top guy never went down
to see what was happening on the shop
floor hurt this you know dynamism and
their system of innovation I think
that's the big challenge that China has
today even though it's very difficult
you know it's sort of a mirror image and
essentially it's in terms of the advice
that you would give the US versus China
the u.s. you're basically saying
acknowledge the government and reward it
for being a patient VC in China you're
saying okay you got the patient VC part
covered but you need a whole bloody
ecosystem that can take advantage of
that and you don't have it yet yeah
except that the terminology ecosystem is
one thing I was trying to challenge
because it is the trendy word today you
know innovation ecosystem and my point
is hey be careful you know if you know
anything about biology co systems can be
you know predator-prey and you know
parasitic versus symbiotic and we just
don't even have it because we don't
engage in this in in this you know
conversation enough about what kind of
public what kind of private not public
versus private then I think and what I'm
arguing is that we've built very
parasitic ecosystems where we have
socialized there is privatized reward
and this is really hurting future
innovation but also making our societies
not very inclusive thank you for a way
better than Earth
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you